like what's what's like a day in the
life of you know an area
it depends how much work you have if
you're doing a civilized manga then you
wake up you go you go to sleep right and
you do that for like maybe like a month
oh wow do you have like assistance and
stuff like that um when I did um
metamorphosis I had two assistants oh
like most of the tone work right right
right okay is your office at your home
or do you have like a dedicated office
where you go it was at my home so my
living room was like like desk slime
yeah and you had to make room for two
other assistants on top of that oh wow
it's like on the floor it's like just
cutting tones out that's just like my
image of like you know these kinds of
like small like Manga Studios and stuff
like that like the assistants are on the
floor you've seen them before yeah yeah
exactly exactly how often do you like
get to work on serialized work because I
imagine you just said it takes a lot of
work so like whenever I want to whenever
you want to yeah you know after my first
first
um
what do you call it like volume a volume
yeah yeah first uh book I have a book
yeah yeah like my first book came out
you know and it sells pretty well then
people start giving you like asking you
to do work so and after you you know
gain a little bit of notoriety then you
know you don't really
have any trouble finding work yeah as
long as you want to work you can oh okay
so that I've been lucky in that sense so
you just go on your own schedule awesome
I'm sure you got quite a bit of
notoriety as well like after
metamorphosis all right actually like I
think my first two like gave me like the
most yeah yeah
was it name value oh is that including
the Planet of the Apes no no my first
two
um are books books oh okay I was about
to say I was like this
you're right right right like my first
two like um published books yeah I've
always been curious because obviously
metamorphosis has been very like memed
up in the western
um anime Community okay what's like
what's the Japanese side of things like
how's how's your Japanese audience
reacted to your work and I think
Japanese audience finds my work kind of
like weird
because like like my stuff is uh a bit
different than like the main mainstream
like yeah yeah it definitely is yeah in
a good way I I mean yes it's small it's
most oil driven I think yeah yeah
definitely so like you know people and
but I just keep trying to put like a lot
of like hentai in there to like you know
make it work pay attention
so I mean like
I think my in the Japanese Market my
most
best sellers to my first one right well
that's because it's been out long yeah
so the reaction from the Western
Japanese audience of metamorphosis was
like really different yeah it's not in
Davis wow okay that's interesting how do
you balance like the amount of story you
put in a work versus the amount of sex
scene you put in yeah um was I supposed
to factor metamorphosis
like genuine questions because I was
reading it and I'm like I don't when
would I
maybe like the first three chapters yeah
that's the only point where I felt like
okay the karaoke scene probably was like
the best optimal Point yeah I was like
oh it's like the I don't know how much
people mean the incredible Mr Incredible
which gets more than yourself
that one that one was very confusing I
was like I'm like this is more story or
more porn I couldn't really was it just
like or do you not see it as that it's
just like it is a story that has porn in
it you can do what you want I think
that's the most optimal way of having a
story with sex in it was like some if
you have like a hentai and it's like the
story there's a story for it for the
first five pages and then like the next
20 pages
oh that was me
oh
sorry
I don't know why I don't know what
Google thought we said Google but
so I'm like if there's like a story part
for five pages and like 20 pages of sex
yeah then you can skip the story part
okay then just read the story and read
the sex and you'll be like
and you're done yeah yeah right right so
is it more that you you can't in Japan
you can't draw stories that have a lot
of sex in them without it being labeled
as like an arrow manga
like are you would you say you're trying
to draw more stories and trying to draw
something to fap too in a way
um I think it's
it's a little bit of both but I think
it's
sexier if there's a story
I agree with that yes okay okay so so
like your biggest challenge is not
putting story in uh in your work but
it's incorporating it in a way that
makes sense that should be an integral
part of the story I think okay thank you
someone someone who gets it thank you
that's why you're the legend
why is the goat yeah because you read
some Hentai Manga and you you there is a
very like clear distinction between
here's the storyboard and here's the
second part yeah metamorphosis didn't
feel like a like a porn thing for me
yeah it felt like a really dark story
and very adult yeah
um I think that's why it drew so many
people in though right because like
they're probably going into it expecting
it to be like five pages of story 20
Pages 16 and then you're like hold on a
second but yeah I'm just wondering now
because it made me think like oh does
Japan have like a if it has x amount of
sex in it would they just automatically
put it in the oh it's important even if
the story is very fleshed out and very I
think there's no like there's no a
clear-cut line like porn and like a
story with sex in it because you see a
lot of singing manga with a decent
amount of sex in it yeah yeah sure I
think it depends on like just how much
you're showing right probably I guess so
yeah because like a lot of like saying
in manga and like sex scenes and stuff
like that it's usually like you know you
only see like the top half or you know
like it's like learning faces yeah just
like yeah it's like oh it's like
completely wetted out or whatever
whereas like you know a lot of dojans
yeah it's white it out but it's like
very minimally wedded out yeah you know
do you have like a unconscious page
count that you need to reach in terms of
like I need to show sex for this amount
of patience because I do notice that
with a lot of mangaway it just feels
like okay okay yeah you have a typical
manga it's like 20 odd Pages that's like
five pages of story and dialogue maybe
and then 15 pages of sex I think if you
haven't edited they try to give you like
a set limit yeah like they'll like chill
my dick can only get so hard
so like you know if you making if you're
making a 30 page manga yeah editor would
say at least 20 pages should be sucks
wow
so if you're working under those with
your Clans it's hard to make a good
story yeah yeah yeah because you only
have 10 pages story you have 10 pages of
story right that's why if you put like
if you um incorporate the story Into the
sex then you have you know all those
pages to work with yeah yeah and I feel
like that just made makes makes the work
better in general if you find a way to
incorporate it somehow but like I guess
like I guess it's hard because one so
few other monikers Do It
um and two I I guess you really need to
think about what kind of scenarios
really work in terms of just here is a
scenario that is just not you know a a
baseline scenario of just like oh sorry
big brother I got like stuck in like a
washing machine or something you know
yeah yeah what is that how's that
working
are there any tropes that you really
hate seeing Oh I mean like
I don't hate anything yeah it's really
execution yeah okay you know I see so
it's not so much the device